non la france n'est condamné ni eau d or
ni au déclin et en disant la vérité avec
des réformes courageuses avec la poigne
nécessaire avec le souffle de la liberté
je le sais nous pouvons redresser la
france en cinq ans pour gagner
fatigables pas de flou il faut d'abord
être fort chez soi bien ancrée dans ses
convictions je suis gaulliste
libérale et sociale ma droite et franche
et mon projet radical car la situation
du pays l'exigent depuis ses origines
la france est grande parce qu'elle le
veut
exiger le respect de ceux qui vous
intime de vous repentir parce que vous
n'avez pas à regretter d'être les
héritiers de gemmes d'art général de
gaulle d'un dicton hugo et de louis
pasteur
vous n'avez pas à marcher à l'ombre
vous êtes du pays qui dans le monde a
fait rayonner les droits universels de
l'homme non mes chers compatriotes mes
chers amis vous n'avez pas à rougir
d'être français et c'est cette fierté
française que je veux restaurer la
france en tête
la france au premier rang la france
ensemble la france encore la france
toujours voilà ce que je veux voilà ce
que je vous propose
voilà pourquoi je me bats avec toutes
les gammes élections du 9 au 16 libre et
le française qui a la liberté l'égalité
la fraternité dans le coeur et qui bosse
sommes avec vous avec force vive la
république vive la france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]